[Music]
did you guys watch
the movie cloudy with a chance of
meatballs yes no i think surprisingly
very good what is that okay so for those
of you that haven't seen the movie it's
this animation
it's super cute i absolutely love it but
it's about the scientist guy that
creates
so he lives in in this island that they
only eat sardines
and so he creates this machine kid's
movie yeah it's a kid's movie and so he
ends up making this machine that that
can
whip up any food that you want so you
could be like oh i want a hamburger and
then it makes a hamburger
amber part of the movie but yeah so then
somehow
some thing happens so this machine ends
up in the sky
and then once it ends up in the sky it
starts raining food
so whatever food that he can control
from his computer and it's just
raining that's why it's like cloudy with
a chance of meatballs because meatballs
might be falling if it rained fried
chicken in real life that'd be so
[ __ ] that's what i was gonna ask i'm
like what would you be
like in heaven if like which food would
be fried chicken or sushi
that would be pretty good sushi don't
knock people out just straight up
drumsticks flying
well i mean you should watch the weather
forecast before walk going outside but
if
you i think the drumstick would be a
whole chicken might be like that's not
true well if you drop a penny from the
empire state building that would kill
you
so imagine drumstick even higher from
the atmosphere yeah it's going to kill
three birds on the way down
what if it was every person that's
[ __ ] funny
let's add a magical element to this
where nothing gets destroyed
nothing like you don't get hurt but in
the movie things do get destroyed
well in the movie though but i'm talking
about this situation a magical element
then what i want
is a giant egg over easy that covers the
whole united states at once
and the yolk is like five states i guess
you can't hurt dude that's like a
tsunami man
yeah so god is making a [ __ ] over
easy egg and he just drops it it's like
pla we're all stuck underneath this egg
together what flavor is
yeah but we're not like in middle
america where the yolk is right so we
gotta like eat through the white
we're in the white area oh that kind of
is a representation because this isn't
like the most like that see like that
the egg is like the fattier part the
yolk yeah
outside is like the the healthier people
where people want to go for vanity and
like
that's like the protein and then oh
that's true it's like that
so then the coastal areas are
appropriate to get the white yeah the
the egg whites the
but yeah so so for you would be fried
chicken yeah you'd be a huge
giant egg egg i think if i'm living in
the same world i need to have like
waffles falling down oh yes
but it's saying waffles butter and syrup
too yes
like it's gotta be you know can i put
some more butter
please yeah how about unity i'm weird i
i feel like it'd be something he wants
kebabs
i was thinking steak while i was like i
brought some like vegetables
vegetables eggplant because what i crave
like like
brought snap peas and carrots to the
medium the whole time i'm like what the
[ __ ] those look so good you like veggies
like that
yeah i love veggies you want raw veggies
raisins like a veggie platter
you can snack on that anytime not in our
world yeah
fried chicken and waffles just let them
live in the first
hour you would get sick of fried chicken
the first day no i wouldn't the day
minimum two hours no i wouldn't how much
you want to bet when if i get tired of
the fried
chicken i'll just rip off the fried part
and just eat the chicken and then and
then reset myself like i'm ready to say
no he could really eat the same flavor
for like a week straight and not even
take out the chicken now you got fries
but the best part of the chicken that i
feel like
chicken take out all of them
[Laughter]
all right well the reason why i bring
this up is because you know you guys
know the chocolate
lint oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a
chocolate company l-i-n-d-t right
l-i-n-d-t
we went to the lint store in australia
they have a store
nice yeah so they're from
switzerland they're from ultim
switzerland right so they have this
factory there
and there was this malfunction in the
ventilating process like the coolant
cooling ventilation
and it ended up just raining cocoa
powder in this whole town oh [ __ ]
[Music]
or chocolate snow they're calling it oh
yeah it's like chocolate flakes
chocolate are there [ __ ] animals
literally everywhere i know that's what
i was thinking too
maybe it's not sweet it's not it's
powder it is roasted
yeah roasted coconut bitter so you gotta
call it
don't let the doggies eat it they're
gonna die oh yeah
oh that's dangerous i think they would
like with a little bit of snow
cocoa i hope not dogs love to lick
everything i know they go what's that
oh i shouldn't have ate that yeah like
how
how much like what amount stupid dog oh
it's probably need a lot more they're
gonna have to lick a whole street
it depends on the uh chocolate content
like
dark chocolate would [ __ ] them up yeah
that's even worse especially if it's a
little dog do you think people were
standing outside with their coffee like
yeah too tight some cocoa in their
coffee
dark chocolate is my [ __ ] though man i
love bitter dark chocolate really i
can't get into it i think it's
like like 70 70 dark chocolate yeah 90
is kind of crazy oh ninety percent just
tastes like ass yeah
i've tried all levels of dark but video
how much you like
you said yeah i can't do
i can't do the bitter taste at all i
like it or like black coffee i can't
do it you have to pair it with something
like the more bitter a food is
if you pair it with something that's on
the opposite end of the spectrum oh
have you had dark bitter sweet meal the
dark chocolate uh
kitkat yeah chocolate kitkat's the
better one
oh kitka is my favorite i think that's
subjective i like milk chocolate
i think when it comes to like pure
chocolate yeah i'm like super down for
dark chocolate i think when it comes to
like chocolate flavor like
flavor like actual milk chocolate or i
mean chocolate milk
i can't stand that for some reason you
don't like chocolate milk like nesquik
or
hershey's i don't even like that you
don't like it mm-hmm
do you like chocolate rain
yes chocolate rice if you don't like
chocolate milk are you even allowed to
judge chocolate
oh damn talk about that yeah it's not
the other way around
the other way maybe it's like because
there's a door right here i think
outside because chocolate milk
i feel like doesn't even really taste
like it's just
milk chocolate or like like for example
like um
like protein right when you take a
protein shake and it's like chocolate
flavored i can't do that
that's not chocolate chocolate flavor
tastes like what do you think flavor
i ever get what flavor do you get i'll
i'll do like vanilla just because i
can't do the chocolate oh [ __ ]
really yeah yeah but like regular actual
chocolate like real chocolate i can do
dark chocolate chocolate ice cream's
disgusting how about that
yes rocky road is amazing though kind of
good
i i don't really i'm not a huge
chocolate fan but i like rocky road yeah
but rocky road's different almond from
the marshmallow rocky road is different
from chocolate
yeah chocolate ice cream just chocolate
flavor
it's too much like on the third of the
neapolitan i will refuse to eat the
chocolate that's what i do but you gotta
eat like
like bite like different flavors each
time right what the hell is this
yeah like strawberry vanilla chocolate
strawberry he's like i need to get all
three flavors
yeah i gotta dump it in the chocolate
you gotta switch it up
you start with the chocolate so you get
the worse out of the way it just gets
better and better
hell no i don't even [ __ ] eat that
[ __ ] really no it's disgusting don't buy
it then
yeah that's true when i was a kid i get
the bucket and just eat the vanilla
that would be so mad they would bring
the bucket home and i'm like oh it's
rainbow sherbet
right because you see the colors and
then it's knives sherbet
are they trying to clean it up the
streets or anything or they just left
well that's the thing
so this uh they're trying to get a milk
factor to malfunction
i know let me tell you what
it determines where it was like uh willy
wonka oh
dude what if their city is like factory
man
everyone just becomes obese and then all
the houses are gingerbread
they're kind of cool and everyone's just
fat walking around
and everyone is that's a good fat a
gingerbread man and you can bite them
it's like wally
is that like your dream is that what do
you think of europe when you think of
yeah or switzerland so it's only thought
to tackle christmas in europe i thought
it was gonna be
all these gingerbread people i could
just come up and be like
hola hola
oh that's the wrong part of europe
[Music]
but uh okay so the company they
did so they did end up fixing the glitch
obviously in the in the factory so it
won't be
raining that chocolate dust anymore or
snowing
but they did offer to clean some of the
parts of the town that got really dirty
better
like for example they offered it so like
the photo that
of the car that got dusted with the
chocolate
the company reached out to the owner and
was like hey you know we'll clean it for
you and they were like nah it's okay
no we like the chocolate stain yeah so
like you know what i
i don't know the history of chocolate
but why the hell do like
switzerland and like that little area of
europe do chocolates
so [ __ ] good man chocolates from like
south america right yeah
i don't know they just do chocolate so
well it doesn't even grow there
you know i thought a lot of people were
responding to this story as like
finally something good in 2020. is that
good raining chocolate
yeah like people are i mean imagine like
raining chocolate the locals were happy
about no like people on twitter they
take off their face mask and then
they're just like
oh i like it i like it that's probably
what would happen
it's not [ __ ] fun i look it's like
the cinnamon challenge oh yeah
someone's just coughing their brains off
everyone's all [ __ ] dying yeah the
powder's all fine
the rest of the world's like yay
switzerland and they're like no no i
don't like it
next year everyone's dying from like
some like chocolate lung
infection cocoa cancer oh it's coco
corona
it's like something so nice with that
coconut coconut
that made me think of a corona beer and
chocolate flavored corona beer oh
my god what would that be like but you
know how when corona came out corona
took the beer took a dip
yeah because people are [ __ ] dumb
people actually i ain't gonna buy corona
that's gonna give me corona
that's true that's how [ __ ] dumb they
are dude i feel like i bought hella
corono because of criminal virus to be
completely honest yeah cause you would
just go to the store
whenever you could go to this cheaper at
the time no no but i know a lot of
people were getting it because then they
could post on social media and it helped
like crazy because they're like
i'm drinking the good karana you know oh
i see that's why
that's it i don't you should get a
bottle of corona and go to the city of
corona
and take a picture bottle like with a
bottle of corona in front of the city oh
yeah
and you got to be 19 years old wearing a
crown
family in toronto the city and then
everyone's like oh like you tell corona
ha ha i'm like
no i'm actually there right now like
people thought i was like a joke because
of the time
that's so silly i get it yeah but
chocolate rain if it wasn't for like the
the possible like choking and breathing
stuff besides that kind of nice what
about the dead dog's part
you're cool with that oh and besides the
dead dog sport besides everything bad
besides the bad stuff this is just
raining chocolate
it's just the sweet like oh sweet get it
do you feel like the world is not a bad
place to have to roll
i feel like if enough of it falls into
like the water system then like streams
in that area will just be like chocolate
chocolate and then it will be like the
the river in
willy wonka's factory oh and all the
fish are just like
super fat and oh yeah dead works too oh
chocolate flavored fish i'm down with
that was is there any calories in cocoa
powder
i don't know oh yeah that's such a
little bit bro-ass thing to ask
or what
[Music]
you